so
hello everyone thanks for attending this
session my name is pedro zabe and today
i will be talking about the solution
developed by perkin helmet for coveted
sequencing
the next flex variants are scovichoked
so the emergence of mutants as copied to
variance
associated with changes to transmission
and health outcomes
have shown that tracking and
identification of wipes variants is
critical to establish an effective
public health response
as a consequence of this once a sample
is detected as positive for kobe 19
using an artificial assay labs are
more and more encouraged to find whether
this particular sample contains
a variant of concern or not to do so
three steps are necessary library
preparation
where the sample is made ready for
sequencing the sequencing itself where
the data is generated
and finally data analysis we will review
in the next slides how each of these
steps are handled by our solution in
detail so let's focus first on the
library equation
the next flex body and sick has been
designed to make
covet sequencing easy the kit is
available in 96
and 304 reaction format and it's an
all-inclusive solution
meaning it is that all the components
that you might need to prepare samples
for sequencing are there
the regions the barcodes and the
magnetic bits
also software is part of the product we
will talk more about this later
so now let's go a little bit into the
details of the workflow
as you would imagine the sample so the
input for the next flex variant 6
has copied to kit is extracted genetic
material from the swap
or saliva center was used for visuality
pcr assay
so we take this extracted material and
then first of all
the workflow will convert the rna
containing it
into dna this is a standard in ngs
workflows for rna afterwards
the viral dna will be amplified using
the articular primers that cover the
whole genome of saskov2
and have been thoroughly tested by the
community finally those amplicons will
be processed using a standard library
prep
this workflow has a total turnaround
time of about 7 hours
as we just mentioned the input material
is the same extract used
for rtq pcr assay and there is no need
to do offers extraction or any illusion
no manipulation of any kind is required
samples with different biology can be
used and we know that this could have no
impact on body identification
performance
in fact we've been validating our kids
with real clinical samples and we know
that
most clinical samples that test positive
will have a viral load that is
compatible so it's within the range of
our source
so copic sequencing is an application
where many samples are processed
in this case automation is relevant uh
and then
we thought of just showing a quick
view of the automation solutions we
offer
just remember at parking armor we have
our own automated liquid handlers for
ngs
and we have plenty of experience in this
field our nexus variancy kit
can be used manually and also can be
automated
using our instruments such as cyclone g3
and gs
cyclone iq and c5 so we have all the
scripts readily available
and then different proposals for
automated workflow
depending on the throughput of the
laboratory so we have solutions or
proposals for 96 samples per day
up to more than 700 per day
don't forget that in addition to the
instruments we can provide also the
consumables for automation so basically
working with perkinemer you can have a
single supplier for all your needs for
copied sequencing
now let's review briefly the part of the
process corresponding to the sequencing
first of all we should say that our
solution is compatible with any illumina
sequencer
from an isaac to an obesity
so this our kit is quite flexible and
different sequencing settings are
possible
however we recommend single end
sequencing with a read length of 36
nucleotides basically to have a quick
turnaround time in all cases so
regardless of the sequencing settings
that you use
a minimum of 1 million clusters per
sample
is recommended so just to illustrate the
relevance of the sequencing settings
in time of sequencing please have a look
in the
to the plot on the top of the slide to
see quantitative qualitatively how
sequencing
time is impacted by doing parent or
or by increasing the real length for
example
on the table visual you can see that an
exit instrument
using our recommended settings you can
obtain data
in less than 11 hours whereas most
solutions in the market
are recommending 2x150 which has a
sequencing time of about 29 hours so for
an application where quick response time
is crucial
this is a factor quite important factor
to have in mind
finally in the table presented in this
slide
you can see the clusters generated at
each instrument
these numbers are equivalent to the
maximum number of samples that you can
load per run
if you follow our recommendation of one
million clusters per sample as we
discussed
previously so
in an isik you you can sequence up to
four samples
nexiq which is probably one of the most
used instruments for copied application
you can sequence between 130 and 400
samples
and then with nova 6 due to the high
multiplexing
capabilities of our barcodes then you
can sequence
more than 10 000 samples per run using
an s4 frozen
so now let's talk briefly about the
analysis
part of the process so customers using
the next less variant six has covered
two kit have access to free data
analysis
the solution we offer is a web-based
application
not requiring any installation and it's
really usage really easy to use
just in two steps customers will be able
to drop their first two files so they
raw data and their analysis will start
automatically nothing else is needed
solar performs a number of steps and we
wanted just to
go over them for you to have an
understanding of what is doing
on the first place data
is mapped against the wuhan reference
strain
globally used as reference for salt kobe
2
then accuracy is applied to the data so
to ensure that at least 90 out of 98
amplicons generated by the arctic
primers are fully covered
this is crucial to ensure that we are
not missing an imitation
then the actual mutations are called and
finally
the variant is a sign
in this slide you can see an example of
a real report
generated by the server this is a real
clinical sample as i was telling
so the most important part of the report
is the summary
under this section you will have
the main results of the test you will
have sequencing metrics such as the
percentage of base
cover and then also you can see the
pangolin lineage which corresponds to
the variant that we want to determine
if the variant is considered a spinal
concept
this lineage will be flagged
as craft color after this summary you
have an additional table with all the
changes detected in the sample with
respect to the reference genome
it wasn't familiar with this application
so pangolin is the standard tool used
for saskov2 linux classification and
nomenclature
and here you have in the slide a link to
the website so you can visit
then you will find that in addition to
be a tool for classifying
your data it also contains a lot of
information on major lineages and
epidemiology that is publicly available
i wanted to mention that in this report
in addition to the pangolin language
information
there is resource information based on
next class classification
this is a different open source
algorithm for saskatchewan
classification that is also widely used
as i was telling it's also included in
the report
and then this is all that i wanted to
discuss with you today
just a brief introduction to our our
solution for copic sequencing
thanks for your attention and i'll be
happy to take any questions you may have